some may say that Nier automata is one
of the best games of 2017
and some may say it's one of the best
games of all time now it's been a little
bit more than a year since its release
and to look back on it I have two of the
great minds behind the game taki cetera
yoko taro and four here for translations
is Eileen Matsuoka and we're gonna play
one of those sequences that I think kind
of encapsulates most of the games
features it really shows what this game
is all about and it's also not gonna be
any spoilers in it so but first off
before we get into the game I want to
ask you guys for someone who has not
played near automata
what would you tell them Massa of
Tennyson is good more money automata
palutena cottony a Tolkien sakkubai
[Music]
so it's been a year since release but if
you haven't played the game yet I don't
think you need to play it yeah anymore
dr. Arnold boy young each story me this
monitor psycho no game that the woman
wasn't there on the mother that's nice
thank you but if you think the girls
like well I don't think so at all it
does have a great music as well as great
sound and everything and so if you
haven't played it at please pick it up
and try playing it okay and if you
haven't got a taste of the game yet the
sequence will kind of show you what it's
all about first off I want to thank
taro-san and yoko-san for taking the
time today out of the busy GDC schedule
to look back at Nier automata so we're
playing through the amusement park
sequence and we're gonna have some
developer commentary so you can kind of
tell us the thought process behind some
of these some of the parts in the
sequence and maybe we also have some
questions for you so first I want to ask
newsmen Park is one of the more colorful
sequences in the game did you feel the
need to kind of input something that is
a little bit more colorful because I
know the rest of the game is a little
bit more dark it has this tone of like
the world is
Troy but here everything is very lively
you know about game machine Tokra very
tall to the color for the day I know
Acharya constantly made apparently
scared to move
so they take indica dominant game at a
Caracas or see what have to consider it
a little Milan and Ashoka thought it was
a tunnel Sakai you don't know kiske got
this or no what are you song okay you
can actually River there's a nice doctor
son also not a notification I don't you
know a nice toaster stay you ancient
tonight them so just in the real world
there's just a lot of different places a
variety of places and people and so I
wanted to depict those kind of
differences in the world where there may
be some that are more violent than
others but there are those who do not
want to attack you and this is one of
those areas that you could see where
there are those that do not want to
fight at a local church got a collection
at yeah thorough know what Jeremy coy
mr. Quan ideas get it more
oh no commander Pocono 109 years ago
Kuwait naked a hydro Connie on a UN
General Nina mean our ocean is that
they're on the same authority on the
popular agnostic so um all these machine
life-forms in this area they're very
quiet they don't come and attack you
unless you start to attack them but in
the very beginning of the game when
we're still developing there was this
bug where 9s was just so aggressive that
the minute you walk into the amusement
park you would actually go ahead and
kill all these my scene life-forms in
the amusement park
were there any inspirations for the
specific design of the amusement park
did you look to any other like theme
parks around the world for this or was
it just kind of what you wanted to put
together in your own mind
no at the event you know it's good on
your day and again you think I did it
some porn a stoppage of the karate
mascot is a little wound up but you know
it'll hold its think he won't die other
than their own oh my oh nothing like a
join of the night I shall know of an
item or focus on my stuff so I actually
cannot say that uh it's very different
to say that legally so it is in
amazement Park that is run by this very
dangerous company in Japan that I just
cannot say oh okay all right
doing on that I I know we talked about
this before when we spoke yesterday over
at the GDC show floor but not getting
into too many spoilers but I did mention
that there are a lot of sequences in
your automata that kind of distills the
human condition and shows very different
parts of humanity and I think that you
know the amusement park itself shows a
very carefree version of humanity
through the robots and I know that
Pascal's village is very very
socialistic kind of philosophical sort
of village and then you have the
abandoned factory that is much more like
a religious ran monarchy in a way and
you also have a fourth kingdom that is
like a traditional monarchy do you feel
the need to kind of show the different
sides of humanity or like what you
thought of as society as a whole you
know interviewed a customized Nunda
scared them off when the Taliban doesn't
know Heidi on the guy Stein is scary
demo it ningún todo a monocot you know
not too scary you know you do not cool
it open media tight okay ironic o8 o
guru pluto stay guy kills a window to
moon is K Tomo so no one ever saw it do
not ever pass car number they are a
party tactic idiot okay hello Maureen no
naka de re bar - no it's not no setup de
tocar t so no sama-sama na @ or don't
come at all
I'm just gonna call it our mystery still
you know our patron Omaha Moscow so I
got a tour it was after this Yoko Ono
Nadia topic item there and what Einstein
disco quite a photographer and what I do
I take the money mo collect myself so
said that uh since I wrote the scenario
I can't answer about this but before
that I do want to ask Carl saw what he
thought but Terrace on said that um I I
didn't think about anything
haha creating that part of the Mo's
Dominical that the cosine sorry please
answer please answer so he wants to know
what the question was again just really
short okay yeah did you feel the need to
kind of kind of look back at different
aspects of humanity and each sequence of
the game whether it be the fourth
Kingdom or the amusement park or
Pascal's village today ningún poor
maddening you know the met or do you
wanna know cop do you know mystery still
gotta talk on my MasterCard no machi I'm
thinking II and again with the Ganges
second most through money ceremony
scared them all know what I mean game an
estate sale [ __ ] you don't know about
or step on the moon cut out before
sending it out but you don't know Yogesh
type indeed at the much time so I think
that video games in general day a mimics
the real world in some way and so in
this game I wanted to do the same but
depict with a different type of people
that live in this beginner ski most of
the stores like here you hear your level
that's too high for that protagonist
kind of just went through and killed
that one - bees too powerful right now
so you gave me a call I hacked also
multiple how would I know about the
rumors but way off so if you actually do
play through the game I don't think that
you'll be able to defeat that boss back
quickly maybe a little bit more
immediate right there yeah yeah this is
my new game plus so a chapter select so
sorry if I blazed through some of these
fights too quickly
I'm a new gimmick put us on shaky game
or something
open your utilities I also tell her son
I know is who's from platinum you did a
lot of the combat design so in this
sequence where we transition into like a
2d kind of plane for the battles with
there any particular challenges in doing
the transitions and tweaking the combat
maybe so it made more sense
I know design motifs on a day to day
nice you can only suck opportunity no it
was really no common car for you in its
Latino community uh no - no okay
how did a colony painting community go
mister
yeah so we definitely did take care in a
to have a really smooth transition
between the 3d animated areas and 2d
areas and I did ask our programmer to
really put in his all into doing this
O'Donnell's 3d karatsu Zenon after it
Susie Cara Inomata personal gaming at 32
kini are no salsa no conjugal color and
I you know provocative
atomic Susan you put a concoction
coronet conjugate predict a little - and
from like 3d to 2d or even into a
different type of game after the 2d
sequence we made sure that the controls
don't feel different that you feel like
you're still playing the same game okay
now we're going into boss battle here
and this is kind of one of those things
where it's very layered in terms of the
sequences and what happens because as
we'll see soon that this is also like
one of the first intros into the hacking
sequence which plays a big part later in
the game so what was kind of your your
thought process in designing the boss
battles as I know platinum is very well
known for huge fights so what was the
kind of the inspiration behind
C Mon here me llamo polyposis mo company
you know Donna McDonald game with your
car stereo Cucuy budget proposed
training update day the token is all hot
King
okay huddle it there I don't know - come
on the skillet impose on our part and
I'm against us termite what's this a
little cupcake oil you made up the
customers care no more consequent a at
the door you flew in each night you can
I have to cancel you wanna come by while
you must go again ah-ha-ha-ha-ha
[Music]
your poor Sangha direction serenity
talking almost acaba are more BGM when
they all static you got anechoic us
cockatoo quick to your kanji not even a
day it's got a couple you know that
about the motel turkey mojo codified in
tonight and I thought oh my gosh so we
know what is expected of us as
PlatinumGames creating a boss battle so
we wanted to make sure that it was
flashy and cool on the screen and it
felt good but at the same time since the
game was made by yochelson we made the
the boss moves along with the movement
of the music of the background music and
so I think that it will be very fun and
interesting to play this game while as
you really listening to the music and
and just dive into it that way
[Applause]
on Okinawa Hawaii you don't not working
on the schedule
seriously that you should be good at
least disagree on a lot so you know
thank God hi Jefferson so this boss
actually has different modes of attacks
that it does but because you're so
strong we all actually saw that too but
um it does have a variety of attacks
that it would unleash upon you again for
bosses to redeem their Etobicoke Mozilla
nation but at the same time um he did
say that he did not want to spoil anyone
watching this video so in that sense it
might be really good yeah sorry I'm
overpowered here I did put it on hard
but that is apparently not not difficult
enough for the high level to be that I
have here and all the plug-in chips that
have oh I also want to ask about plug-in
ships because that was probably one of
the more interesting aspects of the
gameplay
one of the more of RPG elements because
I know play we were talking yesterday
that you know platinum hadn't really
made an action RPG before so with the
with plug-in chips how much did you tell
us on put into that or and what was kind
of like the idea of not doing like
traditional levels and like skill sets
but having something more customized
your honor the PI system I don't wanna
scare Domo and another as well you know
now she's telling astonish a combat
soldier normally there are potato can
ask you Doughboy ticket to your ago
probably heh tell you another Punisher
oh no ten-second oh yeah anymore are
wallatoona system with a on the wall he
thought of all anybody sceeto security
system on the schedule soccer's okay
until topologies or in each case system
you can write this using for Android on
all day I don't see Pohamba conduct
ileana system day a hypnotic comment do
you know Joe gets us so in this previous
title there was something very similar
it was called something like the word
system where you would put words
together to have a passive skill
attached to your character and since
this title was a sequel for that I
wanted to have something
similar and because the characters or
androids I thought that the plugin chips
would be a perfect way to tip it back
okay yeah I'm gonna I'm not gonna get
through this boss battle too fast
because I know and a few hits it'll be
over so I want to kind of look at the
different move sets that this bottom
boss battle presents this is focused on
official said that I let them know that
you said that I was on hardmode he was
just really surprised how you're still
really strong again oh okay yeah oh no
no never did you - no but I did critical
oh yeah so because you would normally
come here at around level 10 you're
about five times stronger should have
that character again sorry about that
what was the in terms of either yoga
Sonora taught us on what was your
favorite boss but by the time you
finished the game and now you can look
back what was your favorite boss
sequence get up on skis a pissant Oregon
disco which one is a Yoko Sun Sol this
man naka skinnable
national dominance oh but we can't spoil
anything all right
looks kinda poppy take me not a reformed
imposter they teach all of us about what
it also some of this so at the very end
of the game you can select which you
want to fight with and I would recommend
you go with a smaller one
okay here in the at least after this
boss battle you kind of get a little bit
of a hint of what you're getting into in
terms of the story when we look at the
dead androids and when I think also
before this on the roller coaster ride
9s talks about how to be can call him
nines now how how hard was it in terms
of designing a story where things would
ramp up and then but also the player
wouldn't forget certain aspects that
proceeded like when you get to a certain
point you kind of have the realization
of what is happening how hard was it to
kind of not just drop the hints of what
this game is about but make sure that
the player remember certain sequences
that they can reflect on back on machine
the top of Android on esthetical are
they out a tokamak Yoga is the god Shiva
no but the lines that they owned a great
tea or Hanukkah cetera toka core game
OEt taqueria Satoko hokotan and atomic
re gonna go to Pecos como quiero es que
no mo sono American Pony Nara na Disick
is the Maheen finishin idk night Tina
daughter chemistry motto is listening
and of course I was a little
disconnect
you don't know that they also cherubim
at Hydra State they out of their home
Tony Stonem all the campuses
domesticated star pony
rocket Romano our moon is its mission
like the cottage cheese or at all which
is another the importance of which it's
cookin up the - so I didn't really think
of it too deeply um I wasn't too
concerned of it I just wanted to make
sure to be able to explain what I wanted
to explain at the end of the game but at
the same time I felt that I don't have
to really explain everything that
happens so if anything is left
unexplained I think that that leaves it
up to the players imagination and so
that's the way that I approached that
foreshadowing okay Hajime my buddy what
can I do if i open i okay so there was a
mentor with Ted
sorry Garnica uneven alcohol
up there it's our stylist Ariana 16
documents but I did make sure that um if
you if this is the first time you play I
wanted to avoid a situation where you
don't know what's happening or you don't
even know what's going on you don't
really understand a story and so I try
to make I try to make sure that you will
still be able to grasp what's going on
even while trying to keep things in the
shadow that you won't know and if you
become interested and you can find it
you want to look into it a little more
you can actually find it in the game
okay I know I just went
try to go fishing here so on and ask
what is the best fishing minigame in any
game of all time
there are multiple series next item on
the scary demo it or Imam RA o esta a
toga no naka no my mini game it was the
Tojo start to the day you must get out
the silver dollar game this game got a
full game but a minute maybe a full game
story she gets off on the bus to be
number one thing I didn't say good night
there's a game called a bass fishing
number one we're not sure if it was
released in the West
I'm not sure even
but it's a Super NES game muscularly no
family fishing or it's a Wii game called
family fishing in Japan but I'm pretty
sure it's in the West as well but it's
family fishing in Chicago okay
oh yeah here's also one of the sequences
where that kind of hints more towards
some of the later story elements so I
think that I when I look back on your
automata one of the things I really
appreciate is that I mentioned this
earlier is that you get to a point where
there are certain reveals and what the
story is about and then you carefully
reflect on some of the earlier hints
that were at it and you kind of piece it
together yourself and I think that I
really appreciate what you mentioned in
that you never really spell everything
out for the player and I think that's a
lot more powerful when you make the
reflection yourself and then you kind of
make the realization about the the
certain hits hints that were made
throughout the game so I think that's
also one of the reasons why so many
people connected with this game and I
just wanted to say that like that is
very much appreciated for someone who is
very much into story based games and
something games that do something
creative with narrative in talking about
morality - no kokoro Beckett's car in
the SkyDome oh so you phonies cbt oco-2
game okay Kyra night you know a tomonaga
teddicus kena Priya they are Magento
store Tomo wantoniy Skinner I know Cody
stay totally funny already today the
Katayama car shows no kimochi wa la
estoy tamaño de makan about character
and I did as I was told I studies
Mohammad autumn sky
sorry I didn't know I didn't really
realize that you were being appreciating
would be so I don't really get praised
to that often so I was just very
surprised the home endocrine I dismiss
Chanel you know because I even like
tarasana he wouldn't even praise the
scenario that I was creating wall during
and development oh so it's the Westin
was there he would actually be like like
you like make up sound we think is his
tongue
happy Hannukah excitable Dudley Digges
well I always thought it was great by
since I was I'm shy I can't really just
go out and to him to him and tell him
how great it is probably a question for
both
yogasana and our son here in the in
Pascal's village everyone's waving their
white flags to kind of show that they're
not hostile at least from a narrative
perspective and a combat perspective ha
ha how hard is it how hard was it to
design something where like you can
engage in combat with NPCs who are not
attacking that will very much affect the
story was there a lot particular any
challenges with that or what's the
thought process behind designing a game
in which you can do that I'm a pastor I
say Matt I know question oh ha targeted
in the scale the more like a one oh my
you ain't she also wrote a modest about
it oh cool geeky estamos nakamura tikki
lighter e ho GAE Kyocera coupon yacht mm
oh no catalytic any given day Monica so
check out the cons Oh another Ariana
coming up 30 to cut these so you can
whoa I don't Schooley not the Deuter can
was a crush cut to disco
Scott Scott called oh oh because one toy
we thought there was also a fancy stuff
I'm not sure if it was challenging or
not but I do want to ask a course on if
what he had in mind when designing a
game like that uh Matata
okay he's too curious to know what
serious question is does your character
engine Oktay most of the real context or
for the night oh you're taking our water
inácio Nash is rock guitarist I may need
the opportunity call you take you to you
saw us tomorrow no no no yoga no Kumiko
much done so well rather than just just
doing this ring which mechanical life
forms are your enemies or not or you can
attack or you can't I wanted to depict
it in this way so that you know that
they're all from the same family
of machine life-forms they're all the
same that they are so even the Michigan
life-forms that you're attacking or the
one thing design not - they're from that
same family or machine line forms Oh No
i'ma coordinates us a report about a
given disc a little more out of
character habilitation Ericka Sluka
Sarah was got a technician on disposable
on eco denied though some character who
cuts night communica but I go Conda got
by him dr. pol oh my god but I do think
that I was probably difficult as a
developer to control like the flags with
in areas like this where you can
actually go in and obliterate everyone
in here if you would like to but there
are some characters that you have to
talk to to open up a new line of
scenario or a new side quest but you can
definitely I'm trying to kill them if
you want to but you would need to leave
the village once and come back if you
want to actually go through and see that
scenario line and so I do think that it
was most likely difficult for the
developers to make such a game like that
okay alright well so do you are you
gonna go fishing I I could go fishing if
well I could go back to the amusement
park if you want to end on a high note
of fishing I have to admit I
I said yeah I still haven't caught
anything fishing so sorry if i
disappoint you and the fact that i have
not engaged with the fishing minigame
all that much [ __ ] all to the
benighted a lot of money to do stain
Itoko question what stupid shot should i
dakota the documents here thinks that
it's better if you leave the village
from the left side of the village
oh yeah sorry I mean I thought don't
imagine what I was doing because she's
talking about her love life yeah I know
operator that 600 is quite emotional
okay okay
probably one of the last things I want
to mention is uh insert you talked a lot
about designing a game in which you feel
free
I think freedom of the player freedom
was one of the biggest themes in your
panel over at GDC so I kind of wanted to
also get at how you designed this world
in which it's confined in a way it is an
open world in in the traditional sense
and you can go about your about the game
however you want in the sense that you
can do is your side quests in whatever
order and you can roam around this world
but what does player freedom really mean
to you yeah I know my partner because I
don't do unique on state that's on the
schedule more Eitoku Nakayama open water
today
I don't know what customer side requests
oh oh no Erica and I come to you this is
she's on the Jimbo module on the screen
the more I don't you think I know an
oxidant that he talked of course economy
to talk I know again Dino at the amino
open water donor gave Jack Panchito
considering this carry the more Osaka
day Allah meter staccato sort of player
conceded you do you know do it the one
about knowledge of course oh no you
don't know you don't know what about the
hero can Renzo Pokemon desk a little
more sake stay here oh se-hoon Eva
Conrad yo check out on that do you know
check out their possible game on ecology
do you devolve Kaito Pokemon you know
Guardiola a sonic wants to talk about
vocano Gammage it or not so for me
freedom in game I think it's not so much
how big the world is or what you can do
in the game it's more of your ability to
find out that you can do certain things
so it's that moment that you realize
that you can do something and I feel
like that's what I really wanted to aim
for in this game
rather than trying to expand the world
itself okay yeah do you either terrace
on or yokas on do you have any other
things you might want to add on top of
what we saw here today in your automata
any kokanee automata in Kerensky not
gonna vomit yeah nicest I could talk to
carry much fun tofu in Seoul is no no
protein again was tossed a husband with
action RPG RPG at school generally it's
good title of steak high viscosity title
they are no comedy action stuff is it
doctor - piranha quarter see game on
generals could predict an eternal
Scottish it all not a satellite the
company Judas cosmos mother on the place
at night to categorize a he insulted
available I got this phone it was so as
platinum gains this is the first time
that we've created something that has
RPG and its name so this is our action
RPG and it's the first time that we've
ever tried to work on that type of game
and so it was just very fun for us to
have this kind of experience and a lot
of people have played it's now and have
given us a lot of feedback and I'm just
really glad and happy that we were able
to get into the hands of a lot of people
and so if you haven't played the game
yet
um I would really love that you pick it
up and try playing it in schools Mahuta
baccara it changed what the media
sentimentality that article Jesus she's
a show intellect you don't attend
kurumada know so communal mama guesswork
uh no games focus on eternity asunder
dislike articulate the panna cotta knows
supporters walk who are no
to me cousin optogenetic on like so no
support avocado today on designing what
in Madani a no say resume opacity eatery
oh no no can't stop til today is only on
okay i teach the what was greatest or
more conscious tomas damaged so um it
has been one year since release but we
were able to like this like today we
were able to come in and talk about this
game even after a year we were we did
receive an award at the GDC awards the
other day and we still have so many
things coming out for this game and i
think that that's definitely because of
the support that we had from fans and of
course media like like GameSpot and I
this one year was the year that I really
felt that kind of passion from everyone
for this game and and thanks to that we
do have a lot more that we can try to do
as we go along as we go after this one
year and so it's just a year of so much
gratitude to everyone all right
and I believe with that we can call this
a day I suppose and we are on top of the
world in a sense at the end of our
sequence playing Nier automata and so
yeah I it's wonderful to have both catus
on yogathon here today to talk about one
of our favorite games to come out in
recent years so thank you so much for
stopping by and at least you know
shedding some light behind the process
of making your automata
so yeah anything else you want to add
before we go
that's hi Lenny Lenny got more talk
about Alaska thank you I
[Music]